voiture à hydrogène est promise au plus
bel avenir c'était un vieux rêve
d'écologie c'est maintenant celui de la
planète entière l'hydrogène vers
l'énergie propre et renouvelable
celle qui peut alimenter tout aussi bien
le monde du transport que celui de
l'industrie lourde le problème c'est
qu'on est encore très loin de la coupe
aux lèvres l'hydrogène versé à la fois
un rêve est une réalité on peut en
produire on en produit au québec air
liquide à des installations de
production d'hydrogène vers un
électrolyseur de 20 mégawatts mais c'est
à très petite échelle ont produit
actuellement trois types d'hydrogène le
gris à partir de combustibles fossiles
donc polluer le bleu plus propre à
partir de gaz naturel dont co2 a été
récupéré il appellera l'hydrogène vert à
partir d'eau et d'électricité le
principal obstacle c'est qu'il faut
énormément d'électricité propre pour
produire de l'hydrogène vert pour
produire de l'hydrogène verts il faut
avoir des infrastructures de production
d'électricité renouvelable et il y en a
au québec y en a en norvège on a en
islande mais y'en a pas à grande échelle
dans beaucoup de pays et l'électricité
est déjà utilisée à d'autres fins
hydrogène var est également de trois à
dix fois plus coûteux à produire que
l'hydrogène gris résultats 92 % de la
production mondiale est encore réalisée
à partir d'hydrocarbures
un consortium canadien djihadistes ou
prévoit terminer en 2024 la construction
à terre neuve d'une usine d'hydrogène
alimentés par des éoliennes pour fournir
les marchés européens et surtout
l'allemagne dans le monde l'hydrogène il
ya eu beaucoup d'anticipation et de
hâter de dégonflement de la balloune
parce que les les astres n'étaient pas
en ligne et mais aujourd'hui avec
l'importance qu'on accorde à la
décarbonation on a quand même
différents éléments qui sont qui sont
prometteurs mais encore une fois
l'hydrogène ne sera pas une solution
magique selon le giec dans le meilleur
des cas l'hydrogène vers représentera à
la fin du siècle à peine 5 % de toute
l'énergie utilisée sur terre ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal